it can be hard to make sense of the
dense history of the world of the matrix
that's why we have the internet to
combine the power of billions of minds
and once for all figure out the
confusing timeline of the science
fiction franchise when humans created
the first truly sentient artificial
intelligence the world was pretty hip to
the idea and immediately start building
robots capable of conscious independent
thoughts to do all of the work we don't
want to people live lives of luxury
while they're mechanized workforce do
the heavy lifting drawing this time at
one particular robot named B 166 er
overhears that is going to be
decommissioned fearing for its life the
machine attacks and kills its owner
despite his claim of self-defense the
Court finds B 166 er guilty and orders
his entire product line to be recalled
and scrapped a machine rights protest
evolves into a series of riots quelled
with lethal force by the military and
soon the robots have run out of human
allies while there's governments are
focused on killing off the machines
human sympathizers the robots head out
to try and find their own space the
machines form a new city in Mesopotamia
which they named zero one through trade
with their old masters the robots soon
become the most powerful economy on the
planet hoping to leverage their
dominance into peace the mechanical
denizens of zero one approached the
United Nations and requests that they
can be recognized as a sovereign nation
with the same freedoms and rights as a
fleshie former masters instead the
humans bombard the Machine City with
nuclear weapons hoping to get rid of AI
life-forms once and for all despite
causing massive machine casualties the
nuclear attack on zero one fails to
destroy the machines which leads to the
machine war desperate for a win humanity
takes aim at the machines most obvious
weakness their reliance on solar power
enter operation dark storm the human
races last act of desperation
Malik Singh clouds of nanites human
aircraft to block the Sun from the sky
while humanity's food dies from lack of
sunlight the machines developed newer
more advanced soldiers by $21.99 the
humans invite a machine ambassador to
the UN and the remaining nations on
earth sign an agreement to surrender the
Ambassador announces that every human on
earth is to surrender their body to
their new robot overlords before
exploding a nuclear device decimating
New York with humans are vocally humbled
the machines move on to finding a new
power source drawing the machine war
that started experimenting with a
combination of fusion and the harvest of
bioelectricity
from human prisoners of war that
constructed skyscrapers designed to
house people's bodies and collect their
energy the problem was keeping defeated
humans sedated and compliant with that
golden minds the machines designed a
program called the architect whose
purpose is to make a virtual world that
will keep human brains functioning and
contained the architect creates the
first matrix a literal paradise with no
suffering no pain and no unhappiness
surprisingly the humans reject it why
couldn't people handle living in heaven
Agent Smith as a grim theory about them
as species human beings define their
realities misery and in turn the
architect makes a second matrix that
operates as a living hell but the demons
and monsters running rampant somehow
humans don't like that one either
around this time a program is created to
understand the facets of the human
psyche known as the Oracle the program
theorizes are the real issues that the
architects earlier matrix programs
brought humans are the ability to make
any kind of choice with that in mind the
Oracle helps to design a new matrix this
one simulates human civilization at his
peak around the 20th and 21st centuries
the denizens are allowed to carry out
normal and remarkable lives as citizens
of Earth glory days meanwhile the
Merovingian a remnant from an older
matrix configuration starts operating a
safe house for exiled programs to avoid
deletion that many obsolete machines go
to heaven for protection often in
exchange for their service even with all
the improvements made by the Oracle the
matrix still had flaws bugs were always
going to pop up and over time compile
into bigger and bigger problems to
combat the inevitable system crash the
machines began to introduce a single
person into each new matrix called at
the one each one will be born toward the
end of a matrix cycle roughly a hundred
years after a had begun when glitches
were beginning to pile up to the point
of being uncontainable the one would
hold inside of themselves a compilation
of every anomaly and the matrix
programming and be gifted with
spectacular abilities both inside and
outside of the simulation at the end of
a cycle in the matrix the one who the
Oracle build up as a fated Savior to the
simulations escapees will be led through
a series of events that would take them
to the architect that program would then
reintegrate the ones code into the
machines central processing facility the
remnants of zero one was setting the
matrix and starting a new cycle the one
would be told that scion the real world
human stronghold was a
to be destroyed he could either save a
small handful of humans from the matrix
and help them to start again or go back
to the matrix and fight a losing battle
do you mean humanity to extinction the
hundred-year process occurs five times
with each one choosing to save who
occurred and hope things go better the
next time
the first Matrix movie begins about 600
years after the end of the machine war
the matrix at the end of its sixth cycle
is about some experience at six one in
the form of Thomas Anderson a computer
programmer Anderson's life changes
dramatically when he's taken in by a
group of cyber terrorists led by the
enigmatic Morpheus and the son is told
that Morpheus believes he's the one a
saviour prophesized by the Oracle who
can stop the machines once and for all
he starts going by his internet handle
at neo and begins training aboard
Morpheus a ship shortly after this neo
and his friends are hunted down by
agents programs designed to guard the
matrix from irregularities led by a
program called Smith Morpheus gets
captured by the agents but his
destruction allows neo and Trinity to
escape
almost immediately neo and Trinity mount
a rescue operation and managed to save
Morpheus Morpheus and Trinity make it
out of the simulation but neo is shot by
Smith and killed before he returns the
life of one neo now able to control
aspects of the matrix seemingly destroys
agent Smith with his newfound powers
[Applause]
six months after the events of the
matrix the resistance fighters of Zion
have discovered that an army of machines
will breach their city walls within
three days meanwhile Smith has come back
a chest full of near that he took in the
last movie seems to have changed them
their longer acting as an agent of the
system he now operates as a
self-replicating virus assimilating
other programs and turning them into
copies of himself
the Oracle tells neo that he needs to
find a program called the key-maker who
can take him to the source
she explains that he'll need to retrieve
the key-maker from the Merovingian who's
keeping him locked away in his hideaway
for exiles this leads to a car chase the
ends of neo being led to what he thinks
is a source but turns out to be the
architects at this point the architect
explains everything to neo this is not
the first version of the matrix he isn't
the first one and the idea of his fated
trip to stop the machines as a
fabrication
he's been manipulated from the beginning
by the Oracle in the architect to
deliver the anomalous codes thought
inside of him back to the source the
same way that the five ones before him
were the function of the one is now to
return to the source allowing a
temporary dissemination of the code you
carry reinserting the prime program so
why not just take it from him the
problem comes down to the player matrix
designs he has to have a choice
the architect says that although Nia
won't be able to save Zion from the
oncoming attack he can return the code
to the source again that necessary
rebooting of the matrix and take a
handful of humans out of the program
allowing humanity to start over
ultimately he can return to the matrix
to try and save Trinity which would doom
the human race to die when the program
is over run by glitches and shuts down
neo strays from the path the previous
ones took he goes after Trinity and
manages to safer exiting the simulation
he then discovers that he has some level
of control over the machines on the real
world - stopping half a dozen sentinels
with his mind before falling into a coma
when he wakes up nears consciousness has
been mysteriously transported to a
halfway point between the matrix and the
real world Morpheus and Trinity
negotiate his release and neo rejoins
his friends while the machines begin
their assault on Zion neo and Trinity
take a ship 2:01 Smith however has
managed to break into the real world he
blinds neo in avert
activating Leo's ability to sense
machine code which he uses to defeat the
physical Smith and help Trinity navigate
the way to the source Trinity is killed
when the ship crashes but neo carries on
their neo negotiates a piece of the
machines he'll offer up the code that
they required to keep the matrix running
and eliminate Smith from the program in
exchange they'll stop their attack on
Zion and allow the surviving humans to
live neo sacrifices himself again this
time absorbing Smith into himself all
jacked into the source the gating Smith
and returning all of the programs he
assimilated to their original forms as
the Sun rises on a new virtual day the
architect and the Oracle discuss the new
status quo humans within the program
will be allowed to leave if they choose
to also stay inside the matrix all that
sits close to right with the world as it
can be in a simulated dystopia just how
long do you think this piece is going to
last the offense of the matrix online
take place shortly after the Matrix
Revolutions not long after the truce
humans start surreptitiously
constructing a second Scion breaking the
rules of the ceasefire between humanity
and the machines this leads to further
confrontations between the two factions
escalated by Morpheus since newfound
fanatical desire to get Neos remains
back from the machine city Morpheus is
killed by an assassin within the program
newer more deadly machine surface and
rumors swirl that neo may have survived
his fateful trip to the source then the
matrix online shuts down on July 31st
2009 abruptly bringing to a close a
continuing story of the franchise's most
familiar characters finally Neil Gaiman
short story titled Goliath takes place
in the distant future the matrix still
appears to be running and humans remain
the machines chief source of power a new
existential threat presents itself with
a hostile race of aliens at saxy Earth
the machines pick one unfortunate man
simulate a war in which he trains as a
fighter pilot and once they feel he's
prepared
send him out on a ship into space to
destroy the alien threat the man
completes his task but is no longer
considered necessary to the machines
they leave him to die in space but allow
him to plug into the matrix until he
expires
there's only one thing we have to say to
that check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]